كشفت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه الرسميه ان عددا
من جنود قوات الاحتياط رفضوا الامتثال
للخدمه للخدمه العسكريه والمشاركه في
القتال داخل قطاع غزه وذكرت الاذاعه انه
تم استدعاء قوات من الاحتياط بعد بدء
الحرب في غزه للمشاركه في تشكيل كتيبه
عسكريه جديده مهمتها الدفاع عن بلدات غلاف
غزه ومستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه غير انهم
فوجئوا خلال عملي التدريب والتجهيز بابلاغ
بانهم سيدخلون الى غزه للمشاركه في اعمال
قتاليه تشمل ما يصفه الجيش بتطهير المنازل
من المسلحين والبحث عن وسائل قتاليه
واسلحه وانفاق وذلك دون الخضوع لتدريبات
ملائمه لهذه المهام وفي مقابلات اجرتها
الاذاعه مع عدد من الجنود ذكروا ان نصف
المقاتلين في الكتيبه انسحبوا ورفضوا
الامتثال للاوامر
ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
عميد الياس حنا ولو بدانا من هذا الخبر
الذي كشفت عنه الاذاعه الاسرائيليه ان نصف
جنود الاحتياط رفضوا الامتثال للخدمه
لاوامر الخدمه العسكريه والمشاركه في
القتال داخل قطاع غزه ما دلالات هذا الرفض
وما دلالات ايضا طلب الجيش الاسرائيلي من
هؤلاء الدخول الى قطاع غزه رغم انهم لم
يخضعوا للتدريبات اللازمه لهذه
المهام ايه السي امرين مهمين اولا انعكاس
الحاله العملان والتكتيكيه داخل غزه
ارتفاع عدد الاصابات ارتفاع عدد المعطوبين
ارتفاع ال انخفاض المعنويات وبالتالي بعد
10 وثلاثه ايام او اربعه عدم القدر على
تحقيق شيء وبالتالي الطلب الى تعويض
القتال في الداخل هذا الامر يؤثر على
معنويات العسكر وبالتالي يصبح هناك تردد
اثنين ان هذه القوات ليست مجهزه اذا كانت
من الاحتياط يكون لديها وظيفه معينه ولكن
كل هذا الامر السي هو بسبب ما يجري في
داخل قطاع غزه الحرب الاكثر تعقيدا وصعوبه
في تاريخ الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ العام 48
طيب عميد لس حنا اليوم عوده للدبابات
الاسرائيليه الى شمال القطاع كيف قيمت
وجدت هذا الامر بالنظر الى تصريحات
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين في الايام الماضيه
عن ان يعني المعارك في شمال القطاع انتقلت
الى المرحله الثالثه وتقريبا الامور حسمت
هناك ايضا السي هناك نمط معين بدا يتشكل
اي في غزه في الشمال وفي الوسط يعني عندما
يكون هناك انسحاب للقوات الاسرائيليه خمسه
الويه وبالتالي المرحله الثالثه تعود
المقاومه لاعاده تنظيم نفسها وبالتالي
لديها ما يسمى بالحرك والانسياب وهذا
الامر قد يعود سببه الى الانفاق فاذا
الانسحاب يساعد المقاومه وتبدا الاشتباكات
عن جديد وهذا ما حصل بالشيخ رضوان هذا في
الشمال في الوسط انسحاب الكتيبه او الفرقه
36 ادى الى امرين مهمين الامر الاول هو
اطلاق الصواريخ على داخل الغلاف على داخل
اسرائيل وبالتالي الامر الثاني وهو المهم
هو عمليه الانزال للفرقه ال 99 والتي تعمل
حول خان يونس الانزال المعدات واللوجستيه
جوا وهذا امر يعكس تعقيدات الارض والميدان
بالنسبه للجيش الاسرائيلي طيب ماذا عن
متابعتك للاوضاع في في الوسط وكذلك في
خانيونس اي ما الذي يجب التوقف عنده في
تطور المعارك
هناك في الوسط السي المهم دائما اليوم حسب
الحركيه الاسرائيليه وهذا ليس بالامر
الهين والسهل هو فصل المخيمات عن بعضها
البعض وبالتالي اخذ خط صلاح الدين
وبالتالي عص لها ومحاوله خفض قدرات اربعه
كتائب للقسام في هذه المنطقه حتى الان هذا
الامر لم يتحقق والدليل على ذلك انسحاب
الفرقه 36 والانزال الجوي الذي تحدثت عنه
اما في منطقه في منطقه الجنوب اعود لاقول
واقتبس مما قاله قائد الفرقه 99 قال اننا
نحارب ب 720 درجه مثل مكعب روبيك يعني رو
هيدي لعبه الروبيك وهي المعقده جدا فوق
الارض تحت الارض وهذا الامر صعب جدا ولكن
دائما يبقى مركز ثقل العمليات في الجنوب
هو مدينه خان يونس مع تثبيت على الجبهه
الشرقيه عبسان الكبيره عبسان الجديده
وخزاعه